I'm Shelly cake
department here at Yale and it's my
great pleasure
introduce Phil Kitchener whom we've just
been discussing how long it is that
we've known each other it goes back at
least 20 years and at the time I was
considering going to UCSD where the
kitchens were at the time and instead I
ended up here it's taken 20 years but
it's of course a great pleasure to
affect to have a future finally here at
Yale
in when Dale Martin introduced him
yesterday he rattled through some of the
biographies so I won't do that today he
also mentions one or two of the honors
but I wanted to give you a somewhat
larger picture of that among his honors
Professor kitch er has won a Guggenheim
Fellowship he's a fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences he has won
a distinguished Teaching Award he has
won a Humboldt Prize he has won a Lionel
trilling award and he's won a friend of
Darwin Award and I assure you this does
not come close to all of them yesterday
was mentioned that he's got a dozen plus
perhaps books and more articles and then
you would believe so I looked it up now
the most recent CV I could find was some
three years ago and it had 146 articles
on it it occurred to me that if I were
to actually try to read to you all of
his publication just the titles of all
his publications it would use up the
fully allotted 45 minutes or so for the
talk and that would still leave us with
some time for for him to fill us in on
all the articles he's published in the
last three years one of the remark is to
say just that people who are coming new
to Professor kitchens work may not have
an adequate sense of the remarkable
drets
this is somebody who of course now works
on the issues of secular humanism
religion previous to that evolution
creationism biology he started off in
philosophy of mathematics indeed two
early articles one was flux eons limits
and if I understand this infinite
littleness and
one was bolzano's ideal of algebraic
analysis now I know that many of you
came here in hopes that we would learn
more about bolzano's article but even
this doesn't give you a full sense of
the work some three or four years ago he
published a book called an invitation to
rather called a Joyce's kaleidoscope an
invitation to Finnegan's Wake I think
this just gives you a sense of the full
range of interests and we're getting
more of that in this lecture series
actually one or two items of business I
should ask you if you haven't yet done
it please turn off your telephone so we
don't have any interruptions the lecture
is being recorded at the end of today's
lecture there'll be time for questions
and I'll give you some instructions with
regard to that when the time comes
meanwhile let me please just ask you to
welcome professor pitcher back for a
second time today's topic is ethics as a
human project okay thank you that was a
that was a lovely introduction
fully ethical beings are those able to
direct their conduct by judgments about
what they think of as good or right or
virtuous or valuable most of the time
they may act from habit but they
sometimes stop consider what course of
action would be best and act on the
basis of their deliberations they can
subordinate some of their wishes even
their most intense impulses to the value
judgments they accept they can reflect
on those value judgments and discuss
them with their fellows they can ponder
potential techniques for giving their
considerate evaluations more power to
govern their actions so the fully
ethical life requires a complex array of
psychological dispositions and
capacities some elements of it are
occasionally visible
among non-human animals who act in ways
that appear praiseworthy but the only
fully ethical beings we know of a human
many religious people as well as many
philosophers think that ethical life is
answerable to an external standard one
independent of human decisions those who
stop to think about what to do may try
their best to find the right
continuation but ethical success isn't
guaranteed not even if their conclusion
is thoroughly endorsed by the settled
judgment of their society religious
people often locate this external
standard in the transcendent realm on
some philosophical accounts - the
standard is divorced from the natural
world grounded in a domain of platonic
forms or non natural properties or
idealized processes of practical reason
other philosophers resist this kind of
divorce
they hope to explain the standard in
natural terms sometimes they measure the
good by the aggregate of pleasure over
pain among all sentient beings or this
is a particularly bad proposal calculate
goodness in the fundamental currency of
Darwinian evolution reproductive success
now the first challenge that I'm going
to consider - my secular humanism
consists in maintaining that any
satisfactory account of the ethical life
must honor
an external standard call it the ethical
order of the cosmos and that it's
impossible to do so without recourse to
the transcendent there are two options
for replying one attempts to dispense
with any external standard at all
ethical deliberation answers only to
local ethical practice now that looks
disastrous it gives up any touchstone
for assessing the codes of various
societies and as the religious challenge
are predicted it seems to lead to a von
Karamazov and the permissibility of
anything the alternative approach
finding a natural basis for values
suffers from all the
actions commentators and critics have
lavished on particular suggestions the
would-be identifications failed to pick
out the correct classes of actions as
good or bad valuable or worthless and
none can explain the force that ethical
judgments have for us moreover if there
were some external standard to which
innovators were responding at those
moments in history when ethical advances
seemed to happen in recognizing the
wrongness of slavery for example we'd
expect whatever natural facts ground
value judgments to place some
explanatory role in accounting for the
change of mind
you can't understand moments of
scientific discovery without
appreciating the altered relations
between discoverers and the aspects of
nature they detect but history seems to
offer precious little by way of clue on
the natural facts that ethical pioneers
detect for the first time so how should
we meet this religious challenge or more
generally explain the apparent
objectivity of ethical life I think we
need a new framework one that expands
the range of options available I'm going
to develop that framework by following a
fundamental insight of Darwin's of whom
as you've just learned I'm a friend when
we're puzzled about some cluster of
phenomena we can sometimes expand our
options by taking a historical
perspective and thinking about how the
puzzling phenomena have come to be full
ethical life as I said at the beginning
requires a complex set of conditions
tracing their emergence makes it
possible to repose questions of ethical
objectivity to escape from a menu of
options limited by inadequate concepts
developing the account will take me a
little bit of time and objections are
likely to flood in along the way I speak
from bitter experience here but I hope
that by the time the story is complete I
will have assembled resources for
providing answers so let's begin a long
time ago human beings evolved from ants
who had a few of the traits needed for
full ethical life many primates have
genetically encoded neurotransmitters
inclining them to take pleasure in the
company of their fellows sociality
extends deep into the pre human past in
our more recent history hominids have
spent almost all the time periods since
our most recent common ancestors with
the chimpanzees and bonobos that's about
five million years ago in social groups
of a very particular sort bands of about
30 to 70 conspecifics mixed by age and
sex now if you think of this room
probably about right except that there
are too few very young people for all
its neural attractions living together
isn't easy most primates settle for more
sporadic social interactions or severely
limit the number of mature males in the
group or opted for a smaller troops eyes
like the chimpanzees and bonobos of
today our hominid ancestors managed a
more unusual set of social arrangements
their achievement rested on a
psychological capacity recognizable in
our evolutionary cousins and one
inspiring some primatologist to credit
them with the building blocks of
morality chimps and bonobos have the
ability to identify the intentions of
their fellows and based on the
recognition to adjust their own plans so
as to aid the others in reaching the
goals they attribute to them that
capacity I'll call it responsiveness
promotes cooperative projects and
accommodations that reduce social
tension yet the responsiveness is
limited the ally who helped yesterday
proves indifferent today and the lack of
response arouses protest and conflict
eventually reconciliation is needed and
the animals have to huddle together
reassuring one another through mutual
grooming the social life of chimpanzees
even that of the more
bonobos is tense and fragile because
these animals have a capacity for
responsiveness they can live together as
they do because that capacity is
restricted they can't live together
easily
time and motion experts would be
appalled at the wastefulness of three
hours spent in grooming on a normal day
and six hours dedicated to similar
gestures of reassurance when the social
order is threatened possibilities for
profitable cooperative ventures go
unrealized group size is bounded by the
daily demands for face-to-face
interaction human group size only began
to increase in the late Paleolithic
fifteen to twenty thousand years before
the present hundreds of thousands of
generations of our hominid ancestors
spent their lives in the chimp bonobo
predicament how did we escape studies of
chimpanzees show they can control
pressing desires in the presence of an
established social practice as when
members of the troop await their turn
for access to water investigations of
social primates and very young children
reveal a similar capacity for
self-restraint in pairwise interactions
where there's an established pattern of
mutual expectations an obvious
hypothesis is that our hominid ancestors
further extended an incipient ability
for self-control so their conduct became
subject to what I'm going to call
normative guidance from the initial
perception of some forms of behavior as
generating unwelcome consequences and
from the awareness of expectations about
actions in dyadic partnerships they
elaborated the practice of
self-restraint across a widening set of
circumstances with the acquisition of
language came the ability to represent
the types of context and problematic
actions to specify patterns for conduct
those specifications could be made not
only by an individual to bind his own
behavior but in discussion with others
discussion yield
rules for action patterns for life
together structures for a shared social
life passed on across the generations by
methods for transmitting to the young
the law of the group if as
anthropologists suppose the conditions
of hominid social life were akin to
those of contemporary hunter-gatherers
socially embedded normative guidance
would be worked out among adult members
of the groups on terms of rough equality
in challenging environments no mature
individual is dispensable it would be
risky not to allow all voices to be
heard and not to seek an outcome all
could accept for tens of thousands of
years our human precursors worked out
the codes that would have governed their
lives together they continued a venture
initiated at least fifty thousand years
before the present and probably far
older we are their heirs unlike them we
continue the ethical project ethics
didn't begin with the responsiveness of
our remote primate ancestors nor with
the exertion of self control directed by
the perception of mutual expectations in
a pairwise interaction nor even with the
earliest efforts in specifying the
patterns of behavior to which group
members would be expected to conform the
beginnings were almost certainly crude
and simple directives to share with
others and to avoid unprovoked violence
moreover the most likely basis for the
original conformity is fear temptation
to stray was quelled by the anticipation
of punishment to follow a practice
focused on such primitive imperatives in
which compliance is the result of fear
seems unworthy to count as the start of
ethics but socially embedded normative
guidance set the stage for processes of
cultural selection in which elements of
the codes tried out by different groups
competed for transmission across space
and time
besides the winnowing of specific
patterns of behavior selection culled
the techniques through which group
members were brought to feel the force
of the requirements the local code set
down successful experiments built the
human conscience finding ways to make
the commanding voice seem as if it came
from within human beings have acquired a
heterogeneous assemblage of devices for
redirecting their intentions as the
basic fear of punishment has been
supplemented by respect for the group
and its traditions pride in alignment
with the code and corresponding shame
and guilt at lapses from it solidarity
with fellows and more besides in the way
of evolution generally redundancy is
valuable allowing a system to be
buffered against the failure of some key
component contrary to the familiar
philosophical fiction there isn't a
special ethical point of view reach
entertaining some special process of
reasoning or some privileged emotion
there is only a hodgepodge of
motivational devices all of them welcome
none of them acquired at the moment when
ethics really begins the elements of
ethical life were assembled gradually
and it's foolish to seek some non
arbitrary stage which human beings or
possibly hominids crossed a threshold
and truly began the ethical project skip
forward among the first written
documents to survive
dating from roughly 5000 years ago our
addenda two bodies of law testifying
both to the complex forms of social
organization attained in ancient
Mesopotamia and to the pre-existence of
systems of patterns of behavior
assembled over many generations cultural
evolution must have led from the
earliest ethical or proto ethical
practices probably akin to the practices
of contemporary hunter-gatherers to the
codes of the far larger groups who
inhabited the first cities approximately
8,000 years ago the clues from the
Paleolithic
Antti to discriminate among many
possible ways in which the evolution of
culture might have gone but I think we
can be confident about some of the steps
first because of the need to increase
the supply of scarce resources cultures
adopted a division of labour
efficiencies in apportioning tasks as
well as an increase in the number of
cooperative activities probably led to
the generation of occasional surpluses
that allowed for profitable exchanges
with neighboring bands and an expansion
of the ethical framework to cover at
least sometimes people who had hitherto
been outside the protections of the
ethical code domestication of plants and
animals probably brought the institution
of private property
finally the structuring of human life
around cooperative interactions often
with the same partner surely engendered
an appreciation of the importance of
mutual responsiveness that was reflected
in later ethical codes as a valuable
ideal something to be cherished
independently of the extensible goals of
cooperation so arose the conception of
enduring relationships essential to
human life and appreciation of a far
richer set of possibilities for human
existence something already visible in
early Mesopotamian and Egyptian
documents the ethical project has
yielded a repertoire of emotions desires
and ideals quite beyond the imaginings
of its early pioneers to other aspects
of the evolution of the project helped
in addressing the religious challenge by
the time of the settlement of the first
cities human societies had lost the
egalitarian character of the origins
private control of livestock probably
played an important role in generating
the later hierarchies of ore and Babylon
already in the division of labour and
the differentiation of roles a contrast
among rival possibilities for the shape
of human lives may have planted the
seeds of future inequality beyond these
eroding tendencies however
egalitarianism was challenged by
second cultural innovation ethnographic
records testify to the almost universal
popularity of a device for increasing
compliance with the group's code when
its members are outside the view of
their fellows invoke some instrument of
detection a transcendent policeman a
deity in the sky who observes all and is
intent on punishing those who deviate
this idea was probably grafted on to
antecedent beliefs about a higher realm
its advantages are evident and it was
obviously widely borrowed or reinvented
once the idea was in place it disrupted
the earlier equality and ethical
discussion people who could successfully
convince others of their own access to
the policemen's will now enjoyed the
authority to declare how the prevalent
code should be amended ethical insight
became the province of a discerning few
okay a story one short on many important
details probably mistaken about a lot of
others but suppose something of that
general sort is right does it allow us
to talk of ethical truth and ethical
falsehood or envisage any objective
standard according to which divergent
ethical judgments might be assessed when
we look back into history were inclined
to make such assessments from the late
18th century to the present uneven and
sporadic processes have modified the
status of women affording them greater
opportunities chattel slavery is no
longer viewed as permissible in my own
lifetime I have seen an enormous sea
change in attitudes about same-sex
relationships and that sea change is
surely going on visibly at the moment
reaching further back into history the
ancient prescriptions of Mesopotamian
law codes directing that the murder of a
child should be avenged by killing the
child of the purpose
Rita gave way a millennium later to the
more familiar idea of exacting the
murderers own life
hardly the last word but surely an
improvement on the Lord replaced
examples like these suggest that the
history of ethical practice isn't a
sequence of mere changes simply one damn
thing after another global judgments
about progress are problematic
comparisons of the culture of one
society at one time with that of the
same or a different society at a
different time are probably impossible
ethical progress may be unsystematic and
even rare nevertheless with respect to a
sample of episodes in which one pattern
for conduct gave way to a different one
talk of progress is hard to resist
people who have lived through the
transition opposed the thought that it
would be equally justifiable to go back
is this concept of ethical progress
coherent apparently progress requires an
external standard of ethical truth the
abolitionists we what may say recognized
a truth that slavery is wrong at odds
with the dominant judgment of their
contemporaries yet history reveals no
moment at which the relations between
some pioneer abolitionists and the
sources of ethical truth were modified
there's no analog of renkins famous
encounter with a fluorescing screen that
sparked his discovery of x-rays
historical analysis can present the
circumstances under which some early
opponents of slavery first came to
question the prevailing attitudes but it
doesn't supply clues about the character
of any shift in relations to external
sources of truth religious people as
well as some philosophers will see this
as the impoverished consequence of
secularism a genealogy of ethics they
will say inevitably debunks the practice
undermining any attempt to take and take
even our most cherished values seriously
secular humanists might return the
compliment
they might say when the rhetorical
flourishes are scrutinized religion has
nothing better to offer its preferred
ethical order is as hard to relate to
the historical narrative as any
naturalistic surrogate but I think
there's a better reply and that is that
to point out that the skeptical argument
turns on a highly specific notion of
progress even in the case of the
sciences it's not always clear that
progress consists in the replacement of
error by true belief elsewhere in
technology and in medicine for example
progress is typically made through
overcoming the problematic features of
the current situation progress in
transportation technology often consists
in constructing new vehicles to break
barriers previously imposed on travel
progress in medicine is made by
developing new techniques for curing
treating or palliating conditions that
were hitherto painful disabling or even
fatal new propositional knowledge
sometimes serves as a means to progress
but it's not the heart of the matter
recall my narrative of the early phases
of the ethical project socially embedded
normative guidance provided a way out of
a problematic situation whose symptoms
were the recurrent instabilities of
social life and whose underlying cause
lay in our restricted responsiveness to
one another the deep feature of the
human predicament is that evolution has
bequeathed to us a disposition to live
together all those nice
neurotransmitters and a limited capacity
for the necessary responsiveness to
others we can do it but we can't
naturally do it easily or well ethics
began by partially overcoming the
problems posed by this predicament it
started as a form of social technology
if you view progress as problem-solving
the concept of ethical progress
coherent all too frequently our
understanding of progress is limited by
thinking in terms of proximity towards
some fixed goal so cognitive progress is
identified with approximation to the
truth yet it's absurd to suppose some
ideal system of transportation towards
which transportation technology strives
to find its way or some ideal state of
perfect health
that doctors try to help their patients
approximate better to think in terms of
progress from rather than progress to
and make the same switch a perspective
in the ethical case as well if you do
this you abandon a picture that has
beguiled religious thinkers as well as
many secular philosophers the vision of
a pre-existent ethical order something
we strive to discover and to exemplify
in our lives and deeds
there's just the ongoing project always
beset by difficulties never finished the
general predicament from which the
ethical project tries to free us can
always emerge in new guises yet that's
not the only source of new challenges
technological solutions typically beget
further problems new vehicles require
rules and structures for coordinating
their movements systems for enforcing
the rules and maintaining the structures
we need roads and stoplights and traffic
police and Driver education and all the
rest of it a device is introduced to
address an existing problem but the
solution depends on particular
conditions posing the new problem of
maintaining those conditions
similarly the original function of
ethics was to overcome the limits of our
responsiveness but the evolution of the
ethical project has brought new
functions in its Train when the demands
imposed on satisfying one function don't
interfere with the fulfilment of others
the task of technology is relatively
straightforward find a device that does
everything
in practice that may prove difficult but
when functions conflict an additional
issue needs to be resolved given that
addressing one problem requires
sacrificing the thoroughness with which
others can be overcome an order of
priorities has to be established
functional conflict makes difficulties
for other forms of technology and it's
the root cause of why ethics is so hard
the concept of progress on offer is thus
incomplete because new problems emerge
functional conflict is a possibility and
when it arises there must be some
specification of what compromises among
functions constrain progressive change a
primary instance of functional conflict
in the ethical case results from an
important shift in ethical practice the
original function of ethics overcoming
the limits of our responsiveness to
others was initially fulfilled through
normative discussions on terms of rough
equality but with the proliferation of
possibilities for human lives the early
egalitarianism was compromised for at
least the past seven millennia the
ethical lives of many societies have
been torn between answering to the
perspectives of all their members and
maintaining the conditions that allow a
rich menu of human possibilities
typically available only to a small
elite progress can only be determined in
the wake of a decision about the
relative priority of such conflicting
functions so a complete concept of
ethical progress presupposes some
normative stance I'm going to postpone
for a little bit articulating my
preferred stance and just assume that
the original function of ethics problem
of responding to our lack of
responsiveness shouldn't be neglected
specifically suppose the efforts to
increase responsiveness to be prised
even if there are costs for fulfilling
rival functions that allows us to pick
out some progressive transitions in the
history of ethical practice for example
whenever
began to insist that their members not
tell one and other things the informants
believe to be false they attempted to
forestall episodes in which speakers
failed to respond to the recognizable
wishes of their audiences ethical
progress was made through accepting the
precept that deception is wrong
human dependence on others for
information and guidance is a permanent
feature of our condition as we envisage
the further development of ethical
practice commitment to responsiveness
would require the prohibition of
dishonesty the precept will continue as
a stable part of progressive ethical
practice following the pragmatists we
can think of truth as what emerges in
the indefinite march of progress truth
happens to an idea as James says if you
proceed in that way then you invert the
idea of progress as the discovery of
prior truth truth is what you get as you
make progress
so secular humanism can rehabilitate a
notion of ethical truth it can defend a
set of core ethical truths rough
generalizations corresponding to the
good advice you all learnt at your
parents knees lying is wrong is true for
the most part as Aristotle might say or
in a more modern idiom is a good default
policy undermined only when responding
truthfully would exemplify an even
greater failure of responsiveness so
there's an ethical standard against
which the practices of different
societies can be assessed an idea
allegedly unavailable once the thought
of a pre-existent ethical order is
forsworn
yet if the normative stance used to
elaborate the notion of ethical progress
allows for different ways of
compromising ethical functions to count
as progressive some ethical issues may
be permanently irresolvable rival
traditions that strike the compromise in
different
equally allowable ways may progress
indefinitely without ever completely
converging each may regard the other as
committed to an attractive
if subordinate ideal an ideal they'd
like to realize subject to fulfilling a
function they take to be dominant
Society is emphasizing the importance of
a rich set of options for human lives
may try to achieve as much
responsiveness to all their members as
is possible without diminishing the menu
of opportunities beyond a particular
threshold those committed to the
egalitarian representation of all voices
may attempt to proliferate the human
possibilities so long as they don't
retreat too far from conditions of full
equality some ethical questions for
example that of exactly how to trade
conditions of equality against richness
of possibilities for living may lack
determinate answers doesn't account of
this sort really meet the challenge
directed against secular humanism it's
time to respond to some concerns and
objections and that will lead me to
develop the account further a first and
obvious worry is that assimilating
ethics to social technology won't
account for ethical objectivity
technologies are grounded in subjective
preferences directed towards goals
particularly human beings want to
achieve people seek new forms of
transportation for example because
they'd like to reach currently
inaccessible places talk of problems
suggests misleadingly that there are
objective conditions Spurs to action
quite independent of the agents once
that suggests the critic is a mistake to
be a problem is to be felt as a problem
but this objection goes astray in making
the concept of a problem entirely
subjective people can after all have
problems of which they're unaware the
problems inspiring technological
ventures are often recognized but they
can be more or less objective insofar as
the underlying desires would arise with
more or less frequency in the particular
situation in the extreme case when any
person placed in those circumstances
would develop the wish for change it's
wrong to dismiss the envisaged goal as
subject
it's no idiosyncratic whim but a natural
outgrowth of the situation examples from
medicine make this clear to say of
someone with a broken leg of someone's
suffering debilitating depression or
someone in a crisis from cystic fibrosis
that their problems are purely
subjective because they depend on
particular desires they want to walk
they want to experience some vestiges of
pleasure they want to breathe
that's as absurd as it is insensitive
the ethical case is like the medical one
limited responsiveness once pervaded all
aspects of the lives of our human and
hominid ancestors the ethical project is
inescapable we who come late in it live
in ways shaped by its achievements and
its failures but we've no option except
to continue it in some fashion or
another equipped with a wider range of
emotions and desires able to envisage
many possibilities for human existence
and to ponder their worth the only
alternative to ethical life is the
condition chair shared by chimpanzees
and bonobos a predicament surely even
more abhorrent to us than it was to the
pioneers who took the first steps in
escaping from it the record of human
cruelty and indifference even under the
sway of attempts to promulgate patterns
for our conduct undermines any
optimistic thought that a few thousand
generations of our species have equipped
us with some greatly improved capacity
for responsiveness in a world where
actions can easily have a profound
impact on the lives of many invisible
others in which we're knitted together
in a vast web of causal interactions our
lack of responsiveness has an enormous
ly expanded field on which to play the
old disease our limited ability to
perceive and to accommodate one another
can F fluoresce in extravagant symptoms
social tension and conflict on
scale is that an argument for the
normative stance I bluntly adopted
earlier when I asserted the continued
priority of the original function of
ethics or is it intended as such no and
no the genealogy of the ethical project
might teach us to be wary of the claims
and arguments of individuals even of the
hegemony of argument for the thought of
specific people as entitled to speak the
last word on ethical matters was a
consequential modification of a
previously democratic project it's spun
off from an effective strategy for
increasing compliance with the code even
when none of your fellows is able to
monitor you conceiving ethics as the
province of individual authoritative
experts began in supposing a
transcendent standard to which the
authorities had special access among
secular thinkers it survives in
conceiving of a ground of values that
can be recognized by processes of
individual reflection and reason
available in principle to all but in
practice restricted to an especially
wise or astute elite the professional
ethicist replaces the shaman and the
priest my genealogy offers a different
model of ethical decisions and revisions
one in which members of a social group
attempt to understand the perspectives
of the others and share a commitment to
finding a resolution with which all can
be satisfied nothing outside the human
world directs the correct answer but
each human perspective is crucial to the
negotiation to adopt this view is to see
the history of the ethical project as
marked by fundamental distortions as
those who pretend to Authority leave
long lasting marks on ethical practice
by inscribing their own predilections
and prejudices in enduring precepts in
whose name vast numbers of human beings
have been dominated or punished
reasoning an argument have a
place in the formulation of a normative
stance as they presumably did in the
discussions of the small groups who
decided on patterns for living together
but reasoning must be framed by a prior
perspective about goals and procedures I
proposed a framework motivated by
reflection on the history of the ethical
project and by the hope that
understanding what we have been up to
will make progressive change more
frequent and more systematic because the
objective problem of our limited
responsiveness to others is pervasive
and permanent it should be at the center
of our attention to inspiring efforts to
emulate the obvious strategy achieved
when our distant ancestors assembled for
discussions on terms of equality in the
cool hour with respect to many issues
arising for our continuation of the
ethical project the number of those
potentially affected includes millions
even billions some of them who are not
yet born we can't do exactly as our
ancestors did
but reflection on their procedures can
suggest an ideal modification of ethical
practice should flow from discussions
among representatives of all points of
view each assigned equal status in the
conversation each freed from
identifiable errors and each dedicated
to reaching conclusions all can accept
no such ideal can be completely realized
but steps to come closer to it are
readily appreciated actual ethical
discussions would be improved if there
were representation of a broader
diversity of perspectives if the
participants accepted a ban on appealing
to substantive religious doctrines for
otherwise they would fall foul of the
requirement to eradicate identifiable
errors and if they were predisposed
either by temperament or by training to
engage at least in a detached setting
with the aspirations of others
conversations of this sort are the best
ways of continuing the ethical project
conjoined with this methodological
suggestion is a substantive proposal
one committed to the continued
centrality of the original problem of
responsiveness the earliest ethical
negotiations almost certainly endorsed
particular desires for all members of
the group desires for food shelter
protection and stability for example
focusing on that narrow repertoire of
basic needs is inadequate for human
beings to whom the ethical project has
bequeathed a much more complex
collection of emotions and aspirations
the fulfilling life is no longer
delivered by supplying adequate food and
regular sex if indeed it ever was the
analogues of those originally endorsed
desires are contemporary yearnings to
have access to all the preconditions for
a worthwhile life besides the basic
resources required to continue existence
from day to day the preconditions
include opportunities to appreciate a
range of potential possibilities for
human life and to choose freely among
them the tension between maintaining
equality and increasing the options for
human existence illustrates the
phenomenon of functional conflict
because that conflict runs so deep in
the evolution of the ethical project it
must finally be addressed through
demanding that all people be provided
with the preconditions for choosing and
pursuing lives of genuine worth my
proposal insists on a redistribution of
the material resources collectively
owned by our species a redistribution
sufficient to support the material and
social basis whose current absence dooms
most of the world's people to want and
ill health and ignorance and oppression
and lack of choice among the primary
ethical challenges today is the task of
reconfiguring our economic and political
institutions when they currently thought
such redistribution one worry about
egalitarianism is that the economic
arrangements it requires undermine the
ability to maintain the resources it
proposes to divide evenly the pie
shrinks and the equal shares become
miserably small
of course the size of the shares depends
not only on the dimensions of the pie
but also on the number of diners
egalitarians suppose it to be possible
to find a set of economic Arrangements
stabling compatible with the envisage
redistribution provided only that the
human population is kept below a bound a
size taken to be at worst in the
vicinity of the current total so we
should not want to increase and multiply
at least not indefinitely so I offer two
proposals one focused on methods of
ethical discussion the other a
substantive egalitarian ideal to be
entertained in such discussion together
they constitute a normative stance that
fills out the concept of ethical
progress and so completes my secular
account of values but why should anyone
accept these proposals what force to
these claims have on anybody's conduct
the religious challenger and the
philosopher who suspects ethical
naturalism will join forces in raising
such questions I'm going to end with
some brief answers would be natural ists
people like me are sometimes saddled
with an impossible task
give us says The Critic some clearly
defined mode of inference that leads
from purely factual premises to the
action guiding normative conclusions you
offer if you think about it that's a
bizarre demand human beings don't wander
around the world gathering facts and
nothing but facts until one day they
launch themselves into ethical life by
some specialty adroit means of inference
from our earliest ethical stages as
thinking beings we're immersed in a
mixture of factual beliefs and value
judgments transmitted to us by our
elders ethical life is inescapable the
crucial question is how to continue it
part of the answer is easy when
functional harmony prevails when it can
be shown that a proposed modification of
ethical practice better fulfills some
functions and interferes with none that
suffices to justify the change
functional conflict introduces
complications for instances of
functional conflict The Critic
can finally present his demand specify a
method of argument that will lead from
factual statements or if you like from
the mix of factual beliefs and value
judgments embodied in current ethical
practice to a conclusion about the
priority to be given to the conflicting
functions
now I've evaded that demand I've
retreated to weak talk of proposals that
I've muttered about the hegemony of
argument my proposals however don't
descend from thin air they're intended
to be received against the background of
a particular factual account a narrative
of how the ethical project has evolved
to yield the ethical life of the present
despite the fact that nobody knows how
to specify a cogent method of inference
leading from premises about the history
of a practice to conclusions about how
to continue that practice I want to
defend the reasonableness of accepting
normative proposals by reflecting on the
history of normative practices
reasonableness in belief is not always
reducible to the generation of the
pertinent beliefs according to formal
rules or precise algorithms examples
from ethical life reveal changes of
attitude in which people come to see
themselves and their conduct differently
you learn that words and gestures you
didn't intend to hurt have caused pain
and humiliation episodes of that sort
reasonably induce you to reconsider to
adopt a new perspective on what you
characteristically say and do uproot old
habits and to dis subscribe to new
precepts what occurs is not so much a
different selection of statements from
within the same vocabulary as a shift of
frame consider a historical example some
Victorian readers of Bleak House revised
their attitudes towards the Justice of
then-current treatment of the urban poor
they knew that Dickens had written a
novel not a sociological treatise they
already knew at least theoretically and
probably empirically that life in parts
of London was
brutal and squalid they will move to
feel the awfulness of living in places
like Tom all alone their feelings
permeated their hearing of the novels
voices voices praising the institutions
provided for the destitute those voices
echoed things the readers themselves had
previously declared unable now to hear
such declarations as anything other than
Hollow they could no longer pronounce
the old judgments with any conviction
Dickens persuaded them reasonably to
feel larger sympathies for social reform
not only fact but even fiction can do
ethical work argument has to begin
somewhere and chains of inference depend
not only on the premises but on the
categories used in formulating them none
of us ever achieves a Cartesian point
from which all principles can be
scrutinized all categories probed
instead we acquire a frame for our
reasoning picking it up relatively
automatically from the contingent
culture in which we grow if we're to
amend it or to improve it that must be
as a result of our being led to see
things differently facts about others
how others see our treatment of them
facts about the historical evolution of
practices we acquire from a long
tradition even works of fiction and
drama those are our tools for achieving
a change of perspective so at last I
come to the original challenge according
to the Challenger a religious grounding
of values delivers a status no secular
alternative can mimic but how exactly if
the suggestion is that values derive
from some divine will that must confront
the objections to substantive religious
doctrines that I offered our on Tuesday
and it must also address questions
Socrates posed long ago to Euthyphro but
there is a purified religious position
less definite in which the trance
and is identified with the pattern for
our conduct that is seen as the ethical
order of the cosmos but it's only
accessible to us in the in the shifting
metaphors of the various religions under
these circumstances it seems to me we
have obvious concerns about how we can
be guided by a source so little
accessible and if you worry about why
you should care about the values
generated by continuing the ethical
project I think you should be equally
concerned about conforming to an ethical
order so dimly characterized and so
remotely understood by contrast my
secular humanism places humanity at the
center of value there's no need for any
detour through some dim and remote
transcendent no vindication of human
worth in supposing whether literally or
metaphorically that we're children or
servants of God we are both creators and
low sigh of value our work of creation
prompted by the exigencies of the human
predicament as Dewey says morality grows
out of the very conditions of human life
out of that work carried forward in the
ethical project has come nothing less
than a transformation of human existence
through the forging of connections among
people and through the expansion of the
possibilities of human lives as we
reflect on that transformation I think
we should regret some of the details but
I think we should only a thought we can
only affirm the project itself
constitutive as it is of who we have
become and that I suggest is dignity of
values enough thank you
the mic is yours Thanks
we have time for questions a couple of
rules and one bit of announcement so
after the question session breaks off
there'll be a reception out in the
hallway to that side that's which you're
all welcome with regard to the questions
themselves as you can see there are two
microphones at either side if you'd like
to ask a question please come forward
professor Kuchar will call on you do
speak into the microphone because the
whole session is being recorded so we'd
like to hear you and not just the answer
and please begin by identifying yourself
Thanks so if you've got a question come
on up let's do your Billy Graham thing a
whole step forward please president
Kichler thank you for your presentation
my name is Devin Singh a comment and a
question
it seems that given what we a little
that we do know in our studies of
primate groups in terms of the original
our keys and identifications of alpha
males beta males and whatnot that have
been that have been done it seems that
there may be difficulty in attributing a
radical egalitarian state to the early
human communities that seems to be still
a potentially a mythological postulate
so that's more of a combo not sure what
that does to your to your project but
even if we grant the the existence of
those those types of communities
couldn't we also postulate a egalitarian
community with a strong transcendent
ethical project and if so would that be
would that be acceptable to you
if a egalitarian community
maintain its its status with an appeal
to the transcendent would that be
necessarily problematic in the account
okay very good thank you let me say
something about first to your comment
first so here I'm following three people
in the anthropological tradition and
these three people are Richard Lee who
worked on the clone and Christophe berm
who's looked in some detail about
hierarchy in primate groups and
hierarchy in various human groups
untogether grid hunter-gatherer groups
and an article by a guy whose first name
I can never remember but who's whose
last name is mouthed and who draws a
lovely curve high levels of in
egalitarianism in the distant past
coming down in through most of hominid
history to very low to very strong
egalitarianism and then increasing in
the recent presence sort of u-shaped
curve now firm's thesis which i think is
probably right is that egalitarianism
has to be maintained he burned sorry
lee's thesis is that you have to you
have to have substantial social devices
for maintaining it and he's very good on
detailing the ways in which the kong
maintained socially got equality in the
in their small groups and so i mean i go
with that anthropological tradition and
i suggest that since our ancestors lived
for you know most of their derek most of
the existence of our species in small
hunter-gatherer groups they'd be rather
like the hunter-gatherer groups that
people like boom and ly have studied
okay now to the second part okay now you
asked me if I was okay with the idea of
a an egalitarian group with with it with
the idea of an external Stan
rooted in the transcendent my thought
was actually just to defend myself by
trying to show the possibility of of
managing without the transcendence so
what I wanted to say was that that you
don't need the transcendent to have an
objective notion of values that was my
thesis right
but I do worry about groups that take
this detour the fundamental values don't
lie in what we do and the ways in which
we come to the God one another and in
our negotiations with one another but
they are located elsewhere that seems to
me not only an unnecessary detour but
also something that can take the ethical
eye off the points at which it really
belongs which are other human beings so
I think in the spirit of humanism I
would really suggest that the version of
the ethical project in which it is
thoroughly secular is a superior version
than the version which has this extra
add-on feature that you wanted to give
it ok yes
my concern is with our who suffer pain
also the whales
our carbon footprint okay that's a very
serious challenge review like mine if
you like mine is committed to seeing
obligations to to other beings as
arising from our negotiations but there
is no reason I think as we discover more
about the psychological and neural other
beings like elephants and learn about
the the kinship of their sensitive it is
to pain with our sensitivities to pain
to have that inform our conversations in
thinking about how we are to proceed in
our ethical life if you take my ideal of
mutual negotiation and discussion
seriously it's very evident that not all
people who whose who are to be affected
can be represented for there are some
who are too young and there are others
I mean members of our species who lack
certain kinds of capacities so they so
we have to have representation already
of some human animals and those they
have to be there their voices have to be
represented in the conversation by
others similarly I think for non-human
animals and I think we have special
obligations in this regard to those
animals that we have in a certain sense
brought into being those that we have
domesticated I agree with you about the
elephants I agree with you about the
dolphins and the whales and all the rest
of it I think there there's such there's
once once one comes face-to-face with an
understanding of the ways in which they
live the ways in which they feel and so
forth
that provides a very strong arm reason
for thinking about and talking about
with one another about how to treat them
but I think we also have odd obligations
to things like laboratory mice and
chickens on farms and so on because in a
certain sense we have created we have
taken over the conditions of their life
so what I envisage is is a if you like
an ideal conversation in which those the
features of their lives are taken into
account
now you also talked about carbon
footprint and that that brings me to
something that I really really do want
to talk about it seems to me that ethics
today has to be global that is we have
to think globally from the beginning we
only have one planet and our
responsiveness to other members of our
species if we fail to be in sufficiently
responsive to the needs of other members
of our species it seems to me highly
likely that we will destroy it our lives
are so complex ly interconnected at the
moment that it seems to me that there is
a profound ethical imperative on us to
work together and to broaden the global
common conversation in a way that will
avoid the disasters that are you know
the potential legacy that we leave to
our grandchildren so I think that's a
very important point to bring up and
this idea of of app and human ethics
with some extensions to non-human
animals seems to me to be very pertinent
at a time when some of the things that
we do collectively are endangering the
future of the planet the future of the
species the future of many other species
to promised
a student for my philosophy major and
one reason that made that switch issues
we look at historically millions of
stories have been real-life stories
fictional stories but the ones that we
do remember my worry but the next thing
they might forget it because for over
generations they might forget it because
it's just not as real life is not as a
professional ball so you know how do you
strike it into people
make them want to act okay I'm a
cosmopolitan about this now this
gentleman asked me about a version of
humanism that would add on an external
standard while preserving the
egalitarianism and I said [ __ ] harbors
one too said he put his la to echo
Laplace right I don't have any need of
that hypothesis and I don't even want it
so but I'm going to be more conciliatory
to you I think stories that can get
people involved in the right kind of
ethical conversation are terrific
wherever they come from I don't actually
agree with you that the that the truly
effective stories are confined to the
religious ones and the fairy stories
that we or the the the to the nursery
tales we learn in childhood I think
those are important I think some of them
are very moving I think as long as we
are we are conscious of them as stories
and metaphors this is very much in line
with what I said on Tuesday that we can
use them for all they're worth but I
also want to make a case for Dickens and
Shakespeare and Sophocles and lots of
other stuff too and let it all come and
let each of us choose which of these
metaphors we find most valuable in
continuing our own ethical lives and in
focusing our own ethical values
constantly trying these things out in
conjunction with others since my model
of ethical decision-making is very much
a social one so I'm in favor of this the
important thing is not to give those
stories a literal interpretation then to
to regard them as somehow the last word
uncertain for certain kinds of ethical
matters but if they are seen as valuable
metaphors always integrated in the
service of the of the ethical discussion
which is for me the core then I welcome
so so my so secular humanism doesn't say
you know never read the Bible again
it regards the the you know many secular
humanists teach courses on the Bible as
literature because they regard it as a
tremendously important and moving and
wonderful document and I'd I certainly
don't want to I mean I certainly don't
want to question that in any way I am
Joshua Andreessen thanks for the
presentation
and I think I'm very sympathetic to your
project if I understand it correctly two
worries okay I have in which as kind of
a master value or higher value and and
that you're explaining in terms of
openness and accommodation others one
worried someone might have is that well
one would then use that master value if
you will to look at people's or cultures
and you then grade them on a hierarchy
of ethical advancement of this this
group or this culture is more it's more
responsive more open more accommodating
thus they're more ethically advanced
than some other group and so I'm
wondering how you might mitigate against
that possible where your if that would
be something to embrace I'm wondering
although you seems like you have this
responsiveness as a higher value how you
accommodate indignation how you've
accommodate closure how you accommodate
putting people in prison or or possibly
even go into war with people so where
where is the limit in other words of
that responsiveness or that openness or
accommodation
how does that fit in okay all right very
good I mean the war question is gonna be
very hard but but but I think I can say
some some use of things about the others
so first of all let's talk let's think
about progress and progressiveness I
don't want to talk about progressiveness
across cultures I don't want to say you
know 21st century
America is made as made a lot of
progress on 14th century France okay I
mean I think that's that that sort of
language is really difficult but I do
think that we can look back at our
hominid ancestors who lived in states of
tension and hostility with the groups
the neighboring groups in their area and
couldn't extend whatever ethical
practices or proto ethical practices
they had for the governance of their
life as a single group to the neighbors
I think we can see it as a real
progressive step when they start taking
the neighbors into consideration right
so I think that there are some of these
comparisons that can be made okay now
responsiveness always has to has to make
choices and to be directed so I said
that there are that it was probably true
at the beginning that in these small
groups that started the ethical project
they legitimized certain kinds of
desires for members of the group the
desire to have some food to have some
shelter to be protected etc a second
and I suggested that a similar a kind of
an analogous thing for our time is to
provide for all human beings the
preconditions for a worthwhile life okay
now that's quite compatible with
recognizing that there would have been
in the in those early societies cases in
which in
vigils conflicted and other members of
the group had to arrive at judgments
about how to sort out those conflicts
and and how to respond as it were to a
pair of individuals when you couldn't
respond completely to both of them and
that remains of course with us we have
and that's that's what stands behind a
lot of the developed machinery which is
itself come out of the ethical project
about how to assess who is to blame
etc etc etc so this isn't against
indignation and against punishment but
it's about continued efforts to work
those things out in a framework that
tries as it were to see things from as
many points of view as possible the
limit of that is of course when when
nations go to war and at the heart of
this really at the heart of this view as
you probably can extrapolate already is
the thought that the primary drivers at
the moment of hostility among large
groups of people are on the one hand a
feeling of being having been
shortchanged or humiliated in some way
or subscription to some form of ideology
or myth and that's why I built those
conditions that I did into the ideal
method for ethical discussion terms of
complete equality and exposure of
identifiable errors and I think if those
if those the more those things can be
brought into play in ethical discussion
the and one realized in the actual
relations among people the more we can
do what what I think is actually the
ethically desirable thing which is not
to work out a morality of war but rather
to work out a morality to end war
or to make war considerably less
frequent than it's been